let's say that we have two pumpkin
catapults so let me just draw the ground
here and so the first pumpkin catapult
let me just draw it right over here
that's its base and then this is the
part that actually caught up catapults
the pumpkin so that's what it looks like
it holds the pumpkin right over here
that's the pumpkin that's about to be
shot away and what it does is once it
releases I guess someone presses a
button or pulls a lever the pumpkin
catapult is going to release and so this
arm is going to turn a certain amount
and then just stop immediately right
over there and then that pumpkin that
pumpkin is going to be released with
some some type of initial velocity so
your pumpkin is just gonna go like that
so this is our small pumpkin catapult
this is our small one but let's say we
also have a large pumpkin catapult let
me draw that
so our large pumpkin catapult right over
here similar similar mechanism but let's
say it's arm is four times as long so
that looks about four times as long
right over there so this is the larger
one the large pumpkin catapult let me
make sure to draw the pumpkin to
remember what we are catapulting and
then it will go through actually the
exact same angle it'll go through the
exact same angle and then let go of its
pumpkin this is gonna be a very useful
video because you will find yourself
making many pumpkin catapults in your
life so and then it will let it go and
you will have some linear velocity now
we know a few things about these pumpkin
catapults let's say this small pumpkin
catapult the radius between the center
of the pumpkin the radius between the
center of the pumpkin and the center of
rotation right over there let's say that
this is our well for the large one this
one is this distance right over here is
4 R we also know the angular velocity
when this wildest thing is
moving so we know that the angular
velocity here let's say the magnitude of
the angular velocity is Omega
it would actually be negative if we were
to write it as a vector because we're
going in the clockwise direction because
that's the convention but this right
here is the magnitude of the angular
velocity and just to make that tangible
for you we could say let's say that this
is I don't know two pi radians per
second and let's say this thing while
it's while it's in motion it also has
the same magnitude of its angular
velocity so this thing right over here
is also the magnitude of angular
velocities once again two pi radians per
second so my question to you is how
would the velocity the magnitude of the
velocity of the pumpkin being released
from the small catapult so V sub small
if I put a vector if I put a arrow on
top of it we'd be talking about velocity
since I didn't put an arrow we're
talking about just the magnitude of
velocity you could think about this is
the speed how does this compare to V sub
large we have the same angular velocity
but we have different radii pause the
video and see if you can figure that out
well the key thing to realize here and
we've seen this in multiple videos is
the relationship between the magnitude
of angular velocity and the magnitude of
velocity linear velocity the magnitude
of angular velocity times your radius is
going to give you the magnitude of your
linear velocity so for V small right
over here we could write this we could
write this as V small is going to be
equal to Omega these are the same Omega
that Omega and that Omega is the same in
fact we don't even have to know what
this is we could say V sub small is
equal to Omega times our radius which is
R which is R and what's V sub large
going to be well V sub large is going to
be equal to that same Omega so I'm
talking about this particular Omega
right over here so it's that same Omega
but now our radius isn't our it is for
our so we're talking about so times for
our or if we were to rewrite this this
would be equal to four times Omega times
R four times Omega times R and what is
this right over here Omega times R that
is the magnitude of the velocity of our
smaller catapult or the pumpkin being
released from the smaller smaller
catapult so just like that you see by
having the same angular velocity but if
you increase your arm length by a factor
of four your velocity is going to
increase by a factor of four and so you
have the magnitude of velocity of the
pumpkin being released from the large
catapult is going to be equal to four
times the magnitude of the velocity of
the pumpkin being released from the
smaller catapult